[موسيقى]
ازرق هادئ
بديع الجمال
لفه السجون والسحر والخيال
ابزعته خطوات ثقيله
تسعى للفناء
بدات العمليه في العشرين من مارس عام 2003
تصعيد جديد في عمليات الجيش السوري
يا اهل العرب ارقته دموع ثقلاء ابرياء
لكن ما الذي يحصل الان الان الان
مزقته للحناجر الفرحه
او فشعه بالتاريخ مش هساكم
منع السكان العزل من الخروج من هذه
المناطق الساخنه الهبته مدافع اصوات
المدفعيه الان
وطائرات بدات العمليات العسكريه في تمام
الساعه الثانيه صباحا بقصف مكثف زعزعته ح
وكروب وتقلبات
الرابع عشر من فبراير عام 2005 وبينما
اشتدت
واستحكمت صراعات
واطبقت في البر والبحر ازمات والابرياء
يموتون في نفس المكان في كل بقعه مجتهبه
في كل سبع صحيح
في قلبي كل حدث
[موسيقى]
كنا هناك